[Applause]
well guess what because everything comes
full circle acid wash is making a
comeback and drew's crew member and
designer mikel welch is here for a
little 80s diy fashion
it's one of our very favorite drew crew
members extraordinary designer mikal
welch or is it someone else today oh
baby i am the creator the emancipator in
the architect of rock and roll
i'm no other then little richard
[Applause]
and speaking of fashion there is a trend
because everything in fashion comes full
circle now everybody thinks the 90s is
so novel
oh yeah i mean it's a thing but the kids
they love the 90s baby they love the 80s
but i think we should show them
something that we did back in our day
that they're kind of doing right now
teach us my calories right
all right children today little rich is
going to teach you how to do some acid
washing what i want you to do is to
start out with some rubber bands and
what we want to do if i've already
started here with that one little piece
right here we're going to make little
knots almost think of like little
accordion knots
and you're just going to wrap this
around here a good thing we got some tv
magic because next to them you should
have some that are already halfway
completed
all right so this is what the completed
piece looks like once you kind of gather
everything together now the solution
that we have is three parts water
one part bleach so you're gonna go ahead
and let's place our jeans inside of the
solution here okay and what we will want
to do is let this bleach and water
solution sit for about 30 minutes to an
hour now once you get finished this is
what your pair of jeans will look like
now before you get excited there's more
to it baby so now that we've got our
jeans here the fun part is we can take
our little spray bottle okay and
literally what you're doing is you're
going to go ahead and you're going to
spray right onto your jeans and this is
the completed piece right here look at
it
[Applause]
[Music]
you